so I'm going to talk about how we solve
engineering problems using Python we
have a big problem with a seismic
superficial Rayleigh wave analysis and
we have a lot of data for when we design
new or we upgrade train lines so we use
Python to solve this problem so why am I
talking to you about this a little bit
about myself I'm a civil engineer and I
have another master's in geotechnical
engineering geotechnical engineering is
the science of soil pretty much it's
involved geology and engineering and can
get as numerical as you like or notes I
have a few pet peeves I name only two
because it's the first time I meet you
so I try to be nice
everything should have units and I am
very strong it's not advocate of units
and the output should be in a pre agreed
format and I can't stress enough the
second point that if you are great with
the clients from the beginning then we
solve a lot of problems a little bit of
introduction about the seismic waves
what do they do we have the pressure or
primary waves which are the P waves and
the secondary waves or shear waves you
can see them at the left of the picture
these are the waves that arrive first
when an earthquake happens then we have
the surface waves the rough waves and
Rayleigh waves they arrive last but they
tend to have the biggest impact as you
can see on the slide here this is from
Berkeley and it's the seismograph output
and you consider the Rayleigh waves have
a very high amplitude when the train
moves therefore there any wave moves
with the train a similar effect to the
sonic boom is the ground vibration boom
at the train moves faster from the
surface Rayleigh waves and therefore the
soil fails and this can cause serious
damage to the tracks even with brittle
failure
so the train has to be the sorry the
Rayleigh wife has to be faster than a
train all the time so how do we fix that
problem practically speaking we can
reduce the speed of the train but this
will not be you know you don't want to
take a lot of time to go home right you
want to go home fast so another ways to
engineer the start room the substratum
of the track and implement stiff layers
I added a Jif there to show how the
Rayleigh wave works because I try to
explain it with words and I failed
dramatically so if you watched my talk
at spy at Pinewood UK last year it was
similar to that this is basically part
two Rayleigh waves with revenge so it
came back to haunt me the initial
problem was that we have a lot of data
and geotechnical engineering is not the
procedure that we have replaced are not
designed to deal with a lot of heavy
debt a lot of numbers some of them don't
make sense at all it's like when you
here at first place so we have smaller
medium sized projects ten boreholes
Excel spreadsheets it does the job
everyone understands it everyone can do
it now we have a big project we have a
thousand of boreholes we have a lot of
data we want to analyze this data we
want to export this data on a map and
Excel is slow and this is a portrait of
an engineer when they saw this problem
I'm joking it's not I got it from the
internet
so the problem got a little bit more
difficult for me because the data form
has changed also I think that this one
is missing units so guess who wasn't
very happy who saw that so the three
letters that were not are not included
in the presentation because confidential
data for the clients are so are
stratified edification so it could be
clay it could be sandstone it could be
sand I don't care about the description
of the soil with my problem at the
moment I will care later
when I try to do a comparative analysis
like they will say for example clay has
this amount of this SPT values which
correlates to that stiffness is this
correct so it's good that I don't have
it because I can do a lot of blind tests
what I do have is the thickness and then
I correlate this thickness with shear
wave velocity and I find the shear wave
velocity and then I do my calculations
to find the Rayleigh waves that was last
week in the past I had semi-structured
data everything was nice and you know it
came small amounts of spreadsheets but
now it comes in large CSV files and on
top of that a criterion has been
implemented so after I describe the main
model I will tell you that part two of
the story so what do you think the
linda.thank if I pronounced it correctly
model which said takes the equation from
Victor off to calculate the vs the
Rayleigh wave velocity using the Poisson
ratio equation and then it had a
weighted factor on top of that so a lot
it's a single integral which is fine
because you can do that with numpy you
can calculate signal integrals with non
pi however numpy hasn't got a naval
solver so we chose lianca down instead
of the darken model I'm trying to write
a naval solver for numpy but bear with
me I'm really try and I started with C a
little bit so if you have any advice how
to put a new module into numpy please
come and see me at the break this is the
three-dimensional model of the train and
how it propagates so we have the ballast
which is engineered engineered control
field we know the properties of it layer
1 layer 2 so this stage the layers do
not correspond to different geological
formations so we do not have layer 1
comprising glacial till they're two
comprising bears a mudstone it can be
the same geological formation with
different properties okay so for
that geologist in that in the room so I
used this model Emma started replacing
we can stitch material week is a term
used loosely here material that doesn't
fit the criteria of the Rayleigh wave
velocity we want
I started replacing it with more
competent strata and by copied the
strata
I mean material that can actually take
Rayleigh wave velocity greater than 160
meters per second or at the time it was
a hundred I think and I found out that
when I increase the thickness of the
competent material as you can see I can
increase the Rayleigh wave velocity so
happy days a train can go faster and I
wrote code about it and I was very happy
about it because it solves all my
problems for for now for the time being
so I use the least squares and linear
interpolation to find velocity per Hertz
and I was very happy and then I found
the outliers and I was happy but I had
to explain this to another engineer
saying there's something wrong I don't
know what's wrong we have to look at it
here we have a very stiff material at
the top and then a very weak material
just below one meter below and this is
where you have to look at your data and
say I don't reach a minimum at any time
soon what's going on and this is very
good at cap what happened at this time
because we could send it back to the
person who sent us the data and say are
you sure it was there could you please
do more site investigation before you
build anything it saves money so we were
happy and when we get no data we'll have
one value which again it might be the
case it might not but you'd better ask
right so the replacement criterion that
I had to implement I was told to replace
the in situ material with competent
material so that the Rayleigh wave
velocity for the frequency between 5 to
50 shares is great
116 meters per second which is okay I
mean it's a simple way it's a simple
sentence to translate into an algorithm
it implements to numpy problems here's
an example that I made up the initial
stratum thickness and shear velocity of
the following 3.56 nine point seventy
one and a thousand meters as a half
layer and I deliberately chose very
small shear wave velocity the shear wave
velocity correlates to the Rayleigh wave
analysis so it's fed in the model and
then I started saying that I will run a
loop and I will find where the minimum
Rayleigh wave velocity is greater than
160 and I will stop so that's the
replacement criterion to where I replace
the top meter with stiff material but
then I said to myself what happens later
what happens after 1.5 meters what if I
keep digging and I found something quite
interesting that after 2 meters I think
yes 2 meters no matter how much material
I replace the minimum velocity is the
same which was something that I don't
know if I was expecting it I just I was
just curious to see what's next
so I ran it's to the very end and then I
decided to represent it graphically may
remind you this stage that the
frequencies I had to look in between was
5 and 50 Hertz however I said what will
happen if I exceed 50 Hertz what's
what's there do I have an asymptotic on
the x-axis what happens with the graph
with all those questions in mind I
present you replacement scenario one
where we reached a minimum Rayleigh wave
velocity at about 50 Hertz which is okay
but it's not the minimum we want we want
something more than 160 meters per
second then we want scenario 2 competent
material then you see that we determine
whom after 50 meters
so this is something that I wanted to
communicate my client and say after 15
years we have a minimum do you want to
take a mini moon between 5 and 50 or
your talk knowledge something that's
greater than 50 how will this affect
your design your end of story because I
don't know what happens same happens
with a scenario 3 and scenario for we
start to think they are some toted keep
replacing we have a similar pattern then
the minimum moves further to the right
until you reach really high replacement
depth at around 7.5 meters and less and
higher sorry so when you're from 7.5
meters onwards it starts to be share to
show a behavior like that that the
minimum moves the minimum moves towards
the 0 on the x axis and the value
remains the same so the conclusions are
here a make sure that you know what's
your type again because I had a lot of
problems with data that wasn't fit for
purpose mine if you let your data to the
f degree that it's legible from the
software that you write make sure that
you know that you might need to examine
further than 50 Hertz and always
communicate with the client and make it
a module because at the end of the day
my client will come and ask for it
whichever company does repair works for
rails they can come and say give me the
module she wrote and I can prove that i
actually did science with our data which
is always nice
so that's all from me thank you
[Applause]
Thank You point for questions yes yes
you're talking this sorry okay sorry
so if I got it right the question was
comparing the soil to Newtonian fluids
and asking horizontal on the x axis how
the density or the viscosity or we say
the anisotropy of the soil effects the
propagation is the fixed order we are
with if salt does not the materials and
I'm looting cards do not behave like
non-newtonian fluids so I'm good at that
however we assume that we have powerful
data so it's point data we don't have
continuous data so if we assume to have
continuous data we might have to look at
finite element analysis or something
more detailed so this is a little bit
more generalized data I understand your
point and it's varied and it happens I
can tell you that if you have a lens of
material if you have a lens of organic
soil and I saw that happen on sites okay
it massively affects what you're doing
underneath or on top however they
generally proceed with other types of
testing which is non intrusive people on
sites do sonar to find cavities and very
big differences in like soil density
like we
what is called like with neutral sounds
and things like that if I can explain it
properly
so our ground penetration rather so
there are methods to find it to find if
there's something wrong however we can't
have an intrusive site investigation
every let's say two meters it's not
financially viable and also all these
parameters are weighted and factored so
it's very conservative very conservative
model so it takes into consideration
that if something wrong happens it will
be to have enough time to detect and
repair in material is what you find on
sides so yes what's there already so if
you go up in the mountain for the walk
and you go up on the slope and start
digging you'll remove the mid-ground or
whatever it's late and then you will
find some rocky material or some sandy
material but same stage material it
means on site in Latin and that's the
only Latin I know so don't ask me for
anything else okay just to be clear
Emmanuel and competent material in this
case it means that it's a material that
does the job for us so that's it that
fits the criteria pretty much
yes exactly yes but sometimes we don't
have to replace anything on-site and
that makes people very happy so just to
give like a happy note here
this data the data of them using the
parameters I'm using for the soil
analysis comes from the in situ testing
like the bortles who described before so
this is the output of the looping now I
run this imagine that you have a
thousand bore holes and you have to do
this test for every bottle it takes a
while this is why I stopped the
measuring at when they meet the
criterion now as I said before I don't
have any information to test this data
what happens is that people do side
investigation and they can correlate my
curves to layers if need be but I don't
have this at the moment so I don't know
that will be part three
yes but this does not depict data its
oh sorry sorry
the question was that the graphs here
and let me show them again look really
smooth and the question is how is I
collect the data to make the graph look
so smooth because usually you don't get
that these graphs are the output of
these calculations which use the data
will use the porcelains ratio that's the
knee there are new depending how to
interpret the Greek alphabets and the W
parameter is a weighted factor so the
curve smooth is smooth because you run
integrals on depth and velocities so
even if you have one outlier right here
the curve will still look smooth because
you are integrating under parameters so
you have you don't you're not looking at
the outliers
what's this point outside the graph
you're looking at the behavior of the
graph of then f dash X
I wonder the work that you mentioned on
numpy and you're looking for some
support can you tell us more about that
what what it is you're doing and more
importantly could the non expert in your
field
a PRT yes please then you're not gonna
help me right an avid salford for
differential equations for numpy or show
me how numpy works because i tried to
download it and start typing something
in for submission and at the moment i
failed massively so it's an every solver
is a way basically to solve a
differential equation and I'm trying to
just add it up in editing for reviewing
and that will be my contribution numpy
and will enable me as well to do another
model another seismic model here's a
dunken model to compare the two methods
them
Leigha ground and the dunk model and see
what exactly goes on so it is for my own
use but at the same time it's cough
that's missing and I'm trying to write
it so you can have a chat with Danny
during the break we'll be around later
for drink
two quick sips okay so during the break
this tank down again
[Applause]